all right it is 11:40 I think that's
when we are officially supposed to start
so let's get rolling
I'm going to talk about elasticsearch
suggesters so if that's not what you
were expecting you're in the wrong place
my name is Brett Hazen I'm a principal
consultant at a company called ILM
professional services it's a local
consulting company here in the Twin
Cities we're hiring it seems like
everyone is so if anyone's looking for a
great job in the Twin Cities come talk
to me later I am primarily a c-sharp and
she's c-sharp dotnet and JavaScript
developer although I've done quite a bit
of other things based on what clients
need over the past year I've also done
Python a ton of DevOps both with Jenkins
with Azure DevOps
obviously some stuff with elasticsearch
and some other data stores a runner very
amateur musician sing in a couple choirs
and a bird owner if you didn't realize
that's not a picture of me that's a
picture of a couple of my birds alright
so why did this talk so I was at one
work at work one day programming like
this as we all do was working on a
project where we had metadata about data
so it was basically a tool that allowed
business to figure out what data they
had and there was some health checks on
it so they could look at things like the
quality of the data and we had an API
that was performing poorly and we needed
some more robust search capabilities so
we started using elastic search and then
after that and business saw that there
was value to having a good tool like
that they wanted more things because you
know when you give business something
good they want more good things which is
good it keeps us employed and we get to
solve interesting problems and so we
needed to implement autocomplete and
since we're using elastic search there's
several ways to do it but there's one
out of box ways which is using a
suggestor so I thought that was pretty
interesting there's some other
suggesters I wanted to look into them
more and I thought maybe other people
would find that interesting too looks
like some of you do so that's why we're
here
so the general plan is to cover some
elasticsearch basics because some of the
stuff i'm going to talk about will not
make a ton of sense and
you have an understanding of some of the
basic parts of elasticsearch so we'll go
over indexing and mapping and analyzers
because those are really at the core of
how elasticsearch works we'll take a
tour through each type of suggestor with
an example and then Q&A at the end if
you have questions as I'm going through
feel free to put your hand up and I'll
answer them as I go to you you don't
need to wait to the end if it's
something I just haven't gotten to yet I
may just ask you to wait until after
that but who in here has used
elasticsearch ok so actually quite a few
of you who has used elasticsearch
suggesters ok so not many of you so for
those of you who haven't used
elasticsearch if anyone's not super
familiar with what it is it's a
distributed restful search and analytic
engine and there's some other stuff up
there that's what elasticsearch says it
is the company that makes it is called
elastic if you've heard of the elk stack
it is the Ian elk stack it's really good
at indexing data to make it fast to
search it is not a database I see people
confuse it with document databases it
feels like it is x because you're
indexing json documents like you would
with [ __ ] or something but it doesn't
have transactions like we have in the
traditional relational database world
and it doesn't have some other features
but it is very very good at searching
things so to cover some of those elastic
search concepts elastic search has
indices so you store all your data in an
index and in a particular instance of
elastic search can have more than one
index and each index has analyzers and
analyzers are made up of character
Fulton's character filters tokenizer z'
and token filters an analyzer will have
0 or more character filters one and only
one tokenizer and 0 or more token
filters and these can either be built-in
or custom elastic search ships with a
lot of them out of the box some of them
you actually need to configure to use
we'll look at a little bit of that you
can also define these globally for your
elastic search a cluster instead of just
at the index level
the other really important thing is
mappings and that defines the shape of
data store and elasticsearch so if you
think of like a database schema it's
similar to that there used to be a
concept of pipes and elasticsearch in
the early days were within an index you
would also have type that led to a lot
of really bad analogy is including from
elastic and some of their documentation
where people compared types to tables in
sequel which is just not a great
comparison in people's tried to use
elastic search like sequel and bad
things happen so types are no longer
there they were deprecated for quite a
few versions but as of elasticsearch 7
which is the most recent one they were
finally removed so the way you put your
mappings in has some pretty big
implications on how search works and
we'll look at a bit of that too so what
analyzers do and I think it's going to
be the most instructive to look at this
with a specific example so if we look at
the text domain driven design by example
and we look at it using the standard
analyser which is what is used if you
store data as a text it has no character
filters it uses the standard tokenizer
and the token filters it uses are they
standard lowercase and stop and I should
have updated these slides because this
changed as of elasticsearch 7 the
standard token filter got removed it had
been in there forever as a placeholder
in case they ever needed it and it never
did anything so finally they decided
they could just get rid of it and there
is an API for hoping debug these
analyzers we'll take a look at as well
so if we look at what our text
domain-driven designed by example looks
like after the tokenizer the standard
tokenizer splits things on whitespace so
we'd have these tokens for each word and
after it passed through the standard
filter which again was removed in
elasticsearch 7 nothing would happen
because it didn't do anything
after the lowercase filter it just
lowercases everything pretty
self-explanatory and after the stop
filter which is actually disabled by
default it would not look any different
now what the stop filter does is remove
stop words if you are not familiar with
what those are it's basically just parts
of speech that are super common and not
particularly useful so in the English
language
it's words like by the of so
prepositions those parts of speech so if
the stop filter was not disabled it
would have removed the token bye and so
what would actually be indexed in
elasticsearch from the text
domain-driven designed by example is
these tokens that are left domain-driven
design an example so that's kind of
high-level whirlwind tour of how
analyzers work and how your data is
going to get indexed questions on that
okay so we'll get into what suggesters
are so what is a suggestor suggest
similar looking terms nothing too
earth-shattering but they're pretty
useful and what that means depends on
what type of suggestor you're using
their documentation says that parts of
the suggests features are still under
development but it doesn't say which
parts it said that for quite a while so
I guess they're still working on
something maybe but they won't say what
I can tell you when I originally wrote
this talk I was using elasticsearch
something like six four and now we're on
7.04 I've looked through the change logs
for every version they've released since
then the only things that have changed
with suggesters are bug fixes so they're
a stable feature they've been around for
quite a while there and there are three
types of them there's a completion
suggester a term suggester and a phrase
adjuster we're gonna start with the
completion suggestor so before we move
beyond autocomplete we're gonna start
with it it's prides autocomplete but it
only works based on a prefix so that
could or could not be useful depending
on what type of autocomplete you need to
implement and it stored as a special
data structure that makes it very fast
that data structure is called a finite
state transducer I looked at the week at
Wikipedia article on that to see if I
could give a better explanation and all
the math symbols symbols quickly
reminded me why I didn't
more math in college but they are costly
to build what I mean by that is it takes
more time when you're indexing your
documents to create these because
they're stored in memory which is also
part of what makes them super fast and
you want to be a bit weary of them being
stored in memory because elasticsearch
is built on Java so it's running in the
JVM so you may run up against memory
pressure if you haven't allocated enough
memory to your JVM runtime so just
something to keep in mind so we're gonna
look at that in a demo but just before I
start a couple notes on demos I'm
essentially starting with an empty
elasticsearch incidence it's local
running on my machine there might be
some data in there none of it is data
we're gonna use I'm using the newest
version of elasticsearch 7 which is
7.0.4 I believe so no data is
pre-populated I am going to do all of
the demos using the REST API if I were
doing an actual production application I
would not be using the REST API is there
our client libraries for pretty much
every language that I can think of I
have personally only used the ones for
dotnet they are very good they make it
easy to work with elasticsearch but when
I've had issues with a query not
returning the results I want it's
usually been because I've written the
query poorly it's a lot easier to debug
it using the REST API then through the
clients so for each demo we're gonna
create a new index that's document that
is customized for our needs we're gonna
put some data in and see how the type of
suggestor we discussed works so I am
going to use a tool called insomnia if
you are not familiar with it it's very
similar to postman it's just a basic
rest client and I am pretty positive
that that text is too small for you guys
in the back so let me know when it looks
big enough everyone can read that now
cool
so we're using the REST API the way this
works I've got this running on my local
host 9200 is just that a full port and
the slash test is just the name that
we're gonna use for this index so you
use a put request to create an index
which is a bit weird to me but we're not
here to argue the semantics of rest api
is so what i'm going to do is create
mappings and mappings have properties if
you've looked at elasticsearch before
there would be one more level to this
nesting which would have been that type
that I mentioned was removed so if you
are looking at examples and you see that
difference that's why I'm gonna use one
property and we're gonna call it name
we're gonna give it a type of keyword
and then we need one more I'm gonna call
it suggest so name and suggest here our
arbitrary they're just names that I'm
giving to these properties and then the
type is specifying which type of field
that we want elasticsearch to use and
that controls how this is going to be
indexed so for suggest we need to use a
specific type of completion all right so
we have an index we'll put some data
into it pretty similar URL we're just
gonna add slash underscore doc to the
end and if I wanted to I could also
specify the URL at the end of this but
I'm not we don't need it so I'm just not
gonna bother so we're gonna put some
data in here and since it was finally
nice in Minnesota this past weekend
although you may not believe it today I
was doing some gardening stuff so we'll
use some gardening products so for the
name I'm just giving a text and then for
suggest the syntax for that you can kind
of put in whatever you want in an array
so I'm just gonna use both words and
practice if I was indexing something I
would probably just be splitting on
whitespace to put those in there so I'm
gonna do that what a spading fork to
and how about a fountain
okay so we've got a little bit of data
in there to actually use the suggesters
you use the search endpoint that's
different from some earlier versions of
elastic search and the versions I think
it was only like one in two it's been
different for quite a while there was a
different end point for suggesters
they're part of search now so you can do
both search and get suggesters at the
same time which is pretty useful if I
were to just send an empty request this
is gonna search do everything return me
a some JSON with hits that's the
equivalent to doing an actual query so
if we were trying to do a query for
everything we'd use a match all query
it's gonna return the same thing but
we're not here to talk about queries so
the way you use suggesters is you apply
this suggestor key and then for each
type of suggestor you want to use you
have to specify a name so I'm gonna call
this autocomplete this is arbitrary and
then because we're using the completion
suggestor we need to specify a prefix
I'm gonna use fo because I know there's
data that's gonna come back and then you
specify which type of complete suggestor
so we're using the completion suggestor
and then you tell it which field to use
so we called it suggest and of course I
type something wrong so I am just gonna
go grab part of this quick
so we get nothing back and hits which is
good because we're not searching on
anything in some of the older versions
of elasticsearch that would get returned
by default and you'd need to specify
that you want zero results but we're
interested in is down here and this
suggests and the completer which is what
we called it we're getting back results
so you can see we got back fork fork and
fountain because that is the data that
we specified in here so we can show
those to our users they get a bit of
autocomplete one thing that is maybe not
great is that we're getting back
duplicates if you want to not get those
you can specify another piece of this
request to say skip duplicates and then
we will only get one
we only get fork back once that option
has been in an out of elasticsearch it
was in there in the early days it was
removed for a while then it got added
back in one of the later versions of six
one other thing you may have noticed if
you're paying really close attention to
these results is this underscore source
field this is returning the entire
document which in our case probably
isn't a huge deal but if you have a big
data set that could be a lot of data for
what you're sending over the wire so if
you want to disable that you can do this
source pulse and it streamlines your
results a bit more just being conscious
of what we're sending over the wire so
one last thing I have found useful what
the completions suggestor is if your
users are like me sometimes they are
challenged with typing so if someone
typed in fur we'd get nothing but we
have something similar in there so you
can make the queries fuzzy and what this
lets you do is give some leeway to typos
so you can set this to integers in
practice I've usually set it to auto and
it's worked out pretty well if I do that
again I've typed something wrong
you can see then we do get a result back
so just something you can do to make
life a bit better for your users because
sometimes the worst thing you can do is
show no results maybe if you weren't
getting any results back you just want
to show a message indicating that but
showing absolutely nothing probably
gonna make most users think something's
broken so that is really it for the
completion suggestor any questions on
that
the next suggestion we're gonna look at
is the term suggestor so this is most
useful for correcting a user spelling
and the suggestions that it provides are
based on edit distance which is a term I
wasn't familiar with so what is that
it's basically how many characters need
to be changed for a term to match so if
two things don't match how far apart are
they so for an example let's say the
user provided the text domain but they
screwed up a couple characters there
that corrected term domain has an edit
distance of one because we only had to
move one character or change one
character to make it correct all right
so let's look at a demo so I'm going to
delete the index that we were using
before so we don't need it we'll set up
a new one
you do not need to use a specific type
of field for the term suggestor like you
do for the completion suggestor so we're
just going to do a title of type keyword
we're gonna use books for our data this
time so I'll create that create a couple
documents so we have some data with
which to test
and our request to use the suggestor is
gonna look pretty similar to what we had
before I'll call it spellcheck instead
of prefixed this time we're gonna
specify text I'm gonna use the same typo
we did in our example and then we're
using the term suggestor so we'll do
that and then specify the parameters to
it our field is called title so if we do
that we get back no results which is
actually what I expected but does anyone
have any idea why that is no okay
usually when this happens my first
thought is I've done something wrong
with the query but I know that I've set
this one up right so then my next
thought is usually the way the data's
indexed is not what I'm expecting and
the most useful tool I found for
debugging that is there is this analyze
endpoint so again it's the root URL of
where our elasticsearch instance is
living the index and then slash
underscore analyze and what this allows
you to do is throw text at your index
and see how it's being indexed so the
text we are gonna look at is domain
driven design because we expected that
to show up and then you can tell it
which field you want to use so we called
it title so if we do that this is how it
got set up so the text is only in there
as this is the exact string we gave it
and it's that way because we used the
keyword field type which basically just
takes something as it is and puts it in
there exactly like that you can also use
this end point to check specific
analyzers so we used if we do the
keyword analyzer and I spell analyzer
right we'll get the exact same thing
back so the actual analyzer we probably
want to use is the standard that looks
more like what we wanted because we want
each word
so I'm going to delete that index and
I'm gonna change this type to text which
I know it uses the standard analyzer I
didn't have to delete the index there is
a way you can update mappings it's just
a little bit quicker for the sake of a
demo so I will reindex these documents
and now if we do this search again we
actually get back the corrected option
domain a couple other things I'll point
out here is there's this score that's
basically just how good of a match this
is so how close is it to the text that
the user provided and then there's this
frequency so the frequency is how many
documents in your index in which that
text appears so it could be useful in
figuring out what's probably the most
relevant thing to a user so the term
suggesters probably actually the
simplest one that's the crux of what
there is to it there's some more options
if you really want to look into it I
haven't found any of the rest of them
particularly useful I will mention
elastic searches documentation as
fantastic so if you're interested more
in what's available go check that out
but otherwise questions on the term
suggestor so the question was I've got
this I've got a typo here in spellcheck
so within this suggest object this spell
check here is just arbitrary so I could
actually do multiple suggesters at once
if I wanted
and that's just my way of when I get
them back knowing which suggesters which
so it's just an arbitrary name that I
assign to it any other questions at this
point
so the next type of suggestor is the
phrase suggestor it's like the term
suggester only it's fancier you'd use
this for building a did you mean feature
so if you've ever typed a phrase into
Google and typed one of the words
correctly incorrectly and it's asked did
you actually mean this this is what
you'd use that for it's based on an
Engram language model so what that way
what that is is a way of tokenizing a
string so for an example if we're
indexing the string domain and way you
use a gram size of two we're gonna find
every two consecutive letter combination
from that so if we used anagram size of
two on that text we'd get the tokens do
OMM a a I and I n so that's useful for
individual words but then when we're
looking at phrases people what I've seen
them referred to is shingles instead of
grams so for an example if we're looking
at domain driven design and we use a
minimum shingle size of two and a
maximum shingle size of three which is
like gram size except now instead of
four letters we're doing it four words
we'd get the combinations domain driven
driven design and domain driven design
so that's how we want to think about how
our text is being analyzed in an index
and stored for searching it questions on
that
so I'm gonna delete our index again and
the setup for this is quite a bit more
involved so we haven't seen this yet but
we're gonna have this settings part of
our index now because we need to
configure a specific analyzer so that we
can store the text like that so this is
all boilerplate just what you need to do
for creating custom analyzers so we're
gonna have a filter and an analyzer you
can do specify multiple filters and
multiple analyzers I'm gonna call this
one shingle that name I'm giving it is
just the name that I'm assigning to it
there's no significance to it it's just
how we're gonna refer to it later and
then the type of filter we're gonna use
is the shingle filter and we have to
give it a minimum gram size and a max
gram size and then we need a custom
analyzer too and I am going to call this
trigram because we're gonna make reusing
gram size of three the type of this is
gonna be custom we don't need any
character filters we do need a tokenizer
because remember every elasticsearch
analyzer has one and exactly one
tokenizer I'm gonna use the standard
tokenizer which is just gonna split
things on white space for us and then we
need filter we need to at least use our
shingle filter so that's how you would
set up a custom analyzer so we have this
custom analyzer called trigram that's
using our custom filter called shingle
which is really using a built in type of
filter that's in elasticsearch out of
box we just have to tell it how we want
it to work so then we'll have our
mappings we should be used to seeing by
now
we're gonna stick with our book theme
here and this will be a slightly new
syntax we haven't seen before if you are
indexing the same text multiple times
you can specify what are called fields
and those are basically it just nested
properties so if I want to index title
more than one way this is typically what
I've seen people do and what I do
because I may want to use title as
searchable text but I may also want to
use it as a filter and if you're trying
to filter things you're gonna want an
exact match and then the type of the
property type of keyword is a lot more
useful so you have fields and then it's
just the same syntax as properties so
I'm gonna call this
trigram you give it a type will make
text and then this time we're gonna
specify an analyzer now we haven't
specified an analyzer for anything we've
set up so far because every type in
elasticsearch has a default analyzer so
we're gonna tell it to use our trigram
analyzer and if I've actually typed
everything correctly
no but rather than trying to fix that
I'm just gonna go grab something that I
know works
okay so now we've got an index set up so
we should be able to use the phrase
suggester so we'll stick with the same
books we'd used in our previous example
and this is gonna look pretty similar as
well by now I think you're probably
getting the point that the suggesters
are pretty similar with how you use them
we're gonna use text again for this one
we'll use the same typos as before this
time we're using the phrase suggestor
and when you have those fields the way
that you refer to them is just by the
top-level field then dot whatever you
named the other ones so since we named
to that field trigram it's titled
trigram so if we try running this we're
getting nothing back which is what I
expect is that what anyone else expected
any ideas on what's wrong with it
No okay so again usually if this sort of
thing happens I go to my trusty friend
the analyzer and then ask it all right
what if I send stuff to this field what
is it gonna look like so this is what
we're getting so things are being
tokenized the way we expect it may be
surprising to some people to see that we
have grams sizes of less than two that's
because I didn't specify an option to
take out those when we set up the filter
we certainly could have but the other
thing is everything is still uppercase
twich probably isn't what we want so we
just need to make a minor change to our
analyzer and add the lowercase filter so
we can go back before we start indexing
data and make sure that that's doing
what we want and that looks more correct
so I know that was kind of the same
thing we went through before but I just
wanted to show
that that custom that analyzed and
client works for custom analyzers as
well as out of box analyzers you can
post configurations to it as well so if
you're just trying to figure out how to
get an analyzer to work before you use
it also a useful tool there as well
so we'll put some data back and then if
we go try to use the suggestor again we
actually get something back which is
what we expected and it's got a score
one of the other parameters I found
useful for this is there's one called
confidence by default this is a one and
you can set this to various values and
what it does is basically controls how
forgiving the algorithm is so it by
default it's only gonna return things
that score higher than what was the text
that user provided so if I set this
really low to zero it's gonna provide
more things and you can see it actually
gave us back the typo we put in which
may or may not be useful typically when
I've been working on elasticsearch
implementations I don't want to show
something like that to the user if it's
not actually gonna match anything any
search that they could do against our
elasticsearch instance in the the phrase
suggestor has a pretty neat feature that
will let you actually check against your
index excuse me
it's called kholate and what it lets you
do is actually specify a query so I'm
gonna use what's called a match phrase
query and this is just gonna check to
make sure that the phrases are an exact
match so I'm gonna put title here
because that's the field against which
we want to match and then I'm gonna put
suggestion with this syntax which
basically just means that every
suggestion that it finds is gonna be run
against this query so if I do that
we get zero results back I probably just
screwed up something with the query not
a big deal if you want to get back
results regardless of if they matched or
not you can specify this prune option
and if you specify it in the right spot
you'll get back matches regardless and
it'll tell you if it's a collate match
true or false so it's saying false there
because that didn't match anything so if
you think of why that's useful if I have
users who are searching for specific
things and it's not matching anything in
our website or whatever they're
searching I probably want to know about
that because it either means that our
search is not working correctly and
users aren't able to find what they want
or maybe they're looking for things that
we don't have so if you think like if
this is an e-commerce site and users are
searching for something consistently and
it's not matching anything maybe there's
something we need to add so it's
something to think about one last thing
with the phrase suggestor that's
particularly useful is you can also
highlight things and what that lets you
do is wrap what the corrected text in a
pre tag and a post tag so it makes it
super easy to be able to style things
when you're displaying it to users so
you can see now when it returns the text
it also returns a highlighted version so
I could use that em tag to you know like
italicize or something to give it use
the user a visual indication of that's
what we change from what you put in so
that is it for what I have for the
phrase suggestor any questions on that
yeah so the question was just asking for
a bit more of clarification and how the
Engram filter that I set up came into
play because this looks like it was just
used with the standard analyzer so if I
had just used the standard analyzer I
would have only gotten domain-driven
InDesign by using the Engram filter we
also got the token domain driven and
domain driven design so if we hadn't
done that we wouldn't have actually been
able to match against a frieze because
we wouldn't have had a token of those
phrases does that answer your question
okay any other questions okay so I said
there were only three types of
suggesters that's kind of true but not
completely there's also what is called a
context suggestor it's used with the
completion suggestor but it allows you
to specify context too so you can do
autocomplete but then you can also do
some additional filtering and there are
two types of context currently there's a
category filter which is exactly what it
sounds like and then there's a geo
filter which is also what it sounds like
the Geo filter lets you do filtering
based on latitude and longitude
coordinates so if you think in the
context of if you have a search where
you're searching for locations you could
allow you know use the user's location
to restrict what results they got to
make sure they're the most relevant to
them so it requires a spatial mapping
though to do the geo one so something to
keep in mind it increases the index size
of the completion field so if you're
concerned about the size of your index
you want to be wary of this and it's
entirely sort entirely on the heap
again this is running in the JVM so
tread lightly with this with how much
extra data you're adding and how much
memory you're using so as far as setting
those up it looks pretty similar to our
first example
we're gonna stick with our theme of
books but this time we're gonna add a
John row we'll make this a keyword
because we're probably only gonna ever
use that to filter or display and then
we're gonna have our suggest again we
still have to use the type of completion
but then we're also going to specify
contexts so when you do that contexts
will have a couple pieces of information
you're always gonna have to specify the
type this is if it's a category or a geo
we're gonna use category you're always
gonna specify a name we're gonna call
this genre and then this is an optional
thing but you could also specify a path
and I'm going to do that because we're
already indexing the data that we want
to use for our category so if I do path
I can just say use a genre and if it was
like an S feel that would be you know
like titled genre or whatever okay so
we'll keep using our same text we're
gonna have to give it a genre this time
this sounds like a development book and
because we used that path to tell it to
use another field for the context we
don't have to do anything different with
how we specify this this field if we
weren't there'd be some extra syntax to
it will add another book in a different
genre it sounds like a biography to me
so what do we go to actually use that
it's gonna look pretty much the same
thing same as when we were using the
completions suggestor before we're gonna
give it a prefix they tell it we're
using the completions suggestor tell it
which field to use but if we do that it
is unhappy if you are using contexts
with a completion suggestor you
absolutely have to specify the contexts
so if you want to be able to do it both
ways you're gonna need two different
fields but that's gonna take up a lot of
memory so just something to think about
the way you specify those it's contexts
and this is just an object we called
ours genre and then you specify which
values you want to allow so we had
genres of development and biography so
you can see we're getting back to
results because we allowed all of the
genres we have in there if I take one of
these out and don't change anything else
on the request then we only get one back
because we're only allowing the genre of
development so if you think of this from
a practical standpoint if you're
implementing a search that's a faceted
search so you know we have books if
we're building like a book store
typically you're gonna have a faceted
search where users can select which
genre they want so you could use
something like this to help make sure
that your autocomplete is only showing
them relevant results one other thing
I'm going to show with this and this is
not necessarily unique to the context
suggestor you can do this with just the
normal completion suggestor is we have a
bit more control over that score that
comes back so in addition to just the
input I can specify a weight too so I'm
going to specify a weight of two so
again it's that suggest filled with an
array but this time it's an array of
objects to give it a bit more
information
I'm not going to give a score to our
other book
so if we run this again and include both
our genres you can see that when it
comes back the score here is 2 and it
looks like I had a typo somewhere
and the score for the failure that came
from development was only one so in this
use case since they're the same text not
a huge deal but if you think of maybe
you want to push values from a certain
genre up more because you're trying to
get rid of books if you're like making a
bookstore just one way you control it if
you don't want to have to read index
your entire documents every time you do
that you can also specify it at query
time I'm blanking on the syntax of it
though so if you're interested in it
there's a it's called boosting so you
could look at the documentation and
basically you can influence that score
without having to read without having to
reindex your documents so just another
way you could do that
okay so we're actually doing pretty well
on time questions about the context
suggestor okay so I think we have lunch
after this so if people want to just be
done early that's fine otherwise I have
one related demo I can show you if
people are interested in that I'm
getting some okay
well look at that related demo so I'm
not going to type this all out this is
an example that I took from a project I
was working on when we talked about the
completion suggestor I mentioned that it
only works on prefix that is not always
particularly useful because it requires
users to type the right thing to get
relevant results and if you're indexing
things with that maybe start with a word
like uh they're not going to do that and
then they're not going to get relevant
results not great for users so this is a
bit a beast of an index setup so again
we've got some custom analyzers set up
and there are quite a few in here so
this keyword analyzer is not super
relevant to what we're doing just
another example we're gonna use this
edge and edge Engram analyzer which is
seal similar to the one we were using
before so it's a tokenizer that's
defined down here
it's an edge Engram which is a little
bit different than the
and gram 1 this is useful when you want
to create like more combinations of
words so when you don't want to just
have like these tokens these tokens it's
a bit more flexible and you tell it
which token characters to split on so
it's splitting on letters so when we say
pass in letter here it's saying split on
anything that's not a letter so the way
it indexes the data is not quite the
same and I feel like that doesn't make
sense based on a description so we can
look at what that data actually looks
like what that tokenizer is defined down
here and then there's an analyzer up
here which is using that tokenizer one
other thing I think is neat about this
demo to point out
so our mappings look pretty similar
we've got a name that's a type text then
we've got fields so we've got multiple
fields key word string not super
relevant to us edge and Graham which is
using text and that custom analyzer but
it also has this search analyzer
so when elasticsearch indexes your
documents it analyzes it but when you're
searching against a particular field it
also analyzes the text that was passed
in now if a user is passing text in you
probably don't want it to be run against
an edge and Graham analyzer because
you're not going to get good results so
you can specify a search analyzer that
says hey I want the text to actually
look like this before it searches so
this edge Ngram search analyzer is just
lower casing what they put in to make
the the search case insensitive so we'll
create that we're gonna add a couple
things with names
and this query is gonna look quite a bit
different because it's not a suggests so
we're gonna do a query that's of type
prefix and we're gonna use that field so
you can see I started typing in the word
driven and with the completion suggestor
we wouldn't have received anything
because it's not at the beginning but
because we use that special type of
analyzer we actually got things where
the word was at the end and in the
middle so looking at what that text
actually got indexed like looks pretty
similar to what we've seen before but
again because we use the different type
of query we were able to get different
results so kind of a whirlwind tour
through that but just one other way you
can implement a type of autocomplete
questions on that
all right so any questions on anything
at all we went over okay so either you
all are really comfortable with
elasticsearch suggesters now or you have
no idea what I was just talking about so
well hope it's the former but really any
questions okay if not I will say I am
supposed to remind you to do speaker
evaluations on your way out otherwise
thank you for your time if you want to
get a hold of me after the conference if
you think of questions my Twitter
handles up there at ready Hazen that's
probably the best way to get a hold of
me I'm not super active posting things
on Twitter but I'm on there a lot
otherwise I will be around the rest of
the conference for so Friel feel free to
come ask me questions at any point about
elasticsearch or any other development
topic otherwise thanks for your time and
I hope you all have a enjoyable rest of
your conference